お水か。私はあの、お水で大丈夫です。
ジンジャエールが、あのー、リッキー。
ジンジャエールもんよ。
あ、いや、大丈夫。お店、最初みんなと同じで。
ジンジャエールね、これもね、うちで作ったジンジャエール。
はい、じゃあ、ぜひ。
ぜひ、ありがとうございます。
ジンジャエールはお好きですか?
ありがとうございます。
ジンジャエール、あのー、氷で飲むのにちょうど、お店を。
えっと、サラダも、ワークとして、ロークにサラダの方に、さあ、左もりに、もう少し行ってくれ、今、ラザニア持ってきますよね。
ジンジャエール、あのー、アントビの?
ジンジャエール、アントビの?
行くようにしてるんだけど今年はあの 向こうが来てくれちゃったんだから
どうしようかなという話したところです 行ったほうがいいですよ
行けそう
モロヘイヤのスープ
おいしそう
モロヘイヤのスープ良かったら おかわりしてください
あと7分したらダザニアを出しますので
超で良かった倉田さんの馬のね 個展の時にヤスコさん来てくれて
すごく良かったですね
もうびっくりした
昔あの湯沙さんってすごいね馬術家がいたんですよね
その方を知ってられるからびっくりしました
そうなんか共通のお世代がいっぱいいらっしゃってね
本当ですか
馬術界の中では湯沙さんとか木戸さんとか西田行って金メダルを取った人とかね
あの世代の人が最初の馬術の
木戸先生も何かおとりになったんですよね
そうですよね
はい
あと
あとインナミ清さんっていう方とね
小松崎先生と何も何か共通の次第に
僕が馬術書として知ってる人たちなんですよ
インナミ先生とかの本とか一生懸命読んで
勉強をしました
えーそうなんだ
今でも持ってますよ本を
うん
湯沙さんの
まあそうですね
ちゃんと勉強はしてないと思います
昔の
あの
馬術書っていうと
その
やっぱり湯沙さんとか
うん
そういう人たちが残したのを読んで一生懸命勉強して
わーすごい
ちょっと出まそう
ないよこれ
結構馬術ってこう
伝承っていうか
昔からやってきた人たちの
言葉は違いますけど
うん
すごい参考になりますよね
昔の人はやっぱり
相当乗ってましたからね
なんか人間知らない
いや
人をリアルに知ってるって
リアルにお伝えされてるから
それは大変なことなんですよ
僕たちからすると
そうなんです
だって
ねえ
そんな方に教えていただけないから
そういうチャンスは絶対ないんですよ
私の父親のおかげでございます
パパがねやっぱり
あの
宮内庁のことをやってたし
いろいろなことがあったから
そうじゃなかったらやっぱり
ダメでしたよね
最初に
ねあの大きなと起きたっていうポニーが入ってね 沖縄県のかわいそうそれであのインナミ先生にあの
2人で引っ張っていただいてそういう始め方をしたんですね まだあの小学校の頃
いうまで
いうまあ 長くじゃなくてねあの2つ馬を片っ方に先生がノリになって
あの同じくらいの大きさの馬に私が乗ってあの 風なでを
のマイドイって始めようでそのうちあのそれを取ってしまったんだけどうまいあの 一緒によるものと思っているんですよね
ん
何年か前に柳屋さんのお母様とここで食事
昔は
あの軽井沢の駅間に カシウマがあって
お友達がお店に行くときに
カシウマに乗って行ってたのよって言われたから
カシウマ?
そうそれでそのそのそのそのまた本当の初めの頃はねあの乗れるかどうかあのちったい本当に小さいババがあって
あの一応の乗せてあの見てもらって
そうするとあの街に一人出してくれたんですよ
そういうとしょうがんのってあの自宅のあの別荘まで来てね
あの両親に今日これに乗ってるのよとか言って
えええええええ
それでももう道を一人で自由に歩かせてもらって
それはもうあの最近は全然もう車が多くてね危ないでしょ
本当にすごい大昔よねすごい年ですもんねもうね
一応乗れるかどうかジャッジしてもらって
はいあの
はいあのただ本当にあの
なんていうのは輪乗りとかなんですけどあの
回って止めたりできるじゃなければいい
あの貸し自転車みたいにね
貸し馬も借りてお友達に
じゃあ普通に乗れるって
自転車乗れる
まあ自転車感覚ですね
でもじゃあみんな乗って乗れる
柳屋さんのじゃあお母さんも乗れるってことですよね
貸し馬乗ってかって言ったから
聞いたことないですけどね
聞いたことない
貸し馬でお友達の家行ってたのよって
でもそれってなんか
貸し馬って人がいるんじゃないですか
いや、引き馬ですかって自分で乗るんやろ
4つって
だからお一人で?
うんうん
貸し駅前で馬を借りてお友達の家行って
そう私もそれはやらせてもらえたんだけど
最初にあの見せなきゃダメでね
あの本当に乗れるかどうか
あなたは大丈夫か?って言ったらどうぞって貸してくれるってことですね
うちのお袋がうまい乗れるなんて聞いたこともない
ちょっと孵化したんじゃないですかね
でもこの間おっしゃってた
なんか調子に乗って
今回ね、初日にお客さんで
先生のお友達だった
昔、小学生の頃軽井沢に来て
そしたらすっごく素敵なお姉様が
ローマに乗ってるのを見て
かっこよくて憧れたのよって
あ、柳屋さんのお母さんが言ってた通りだったり
駅前で馬借りて歩いて行ってたっていう
そこ軽井沢でね、一人でこう出してくれたんですよね
外に
私も自宅のお庭まで行って
両親を呼んで
今日はこれなのよって
やっぱりそうなんだ
憧れのお姉様がいたのよって
3日前聞いたばんかって
奥さんは脱がれるんですよ馬は?
いやちょっと乗ってたんですけど
落馬して、怪我してやめたって
花火が上がっちゃってね
それで馬がバーンと跳ねちゃったって
それはちょっと怖いですね
前足が顎にあたって
顎がちょっときれいって
歯が縦にさせて
えぇー
ほんまにそういう話をするって
ほら
怖がってもらうから
怖がっちゃう
でもあの高さって結構
危ないですよね
落ちたら
うん、危ないですよね
軽くポンと落ちればよかったんですけど
落ちたくなくって
下が抜かるんでて
濡れるのが嫌で
しがみついてたから
前の方にブルブルって
毛を蹴られた
落ちるときはパッと落ちた方がね
実はいいですね
あんまり怪我しい
でも本当はね
落ちたらすぐ乗れって言うんですよね
昔の人はもう厳しかったですね
もう厳しくて
私も落ちたとき
ここから血が出てるので
乗れって言うんですよね
もちろんそんなに
お気がなさってたら
乗れって
あの水で濡れて
ドロドロなのに乗れって言うから
それは馬の教えなんです
落とせば終わると思う
でもそれはやっぱり先生の方が悪いよね
そんな方をこうね
乗せて出したなんていうのはいけないですよね
落ちるとちょっと気持ちがへこみますね
それまで調子よく乗っててもね
アメリカはどうなんですか?
乗るところはたくさんありそう
ねえそうですよね
力は覚えている?
力はアメリカにいたとき
えっと
力は覚えている?
力はアメリカにいたとき
えっと
おくらいや毎日 車で30分ぐらいもうもうん
高いでいっ うわーすっすっしたのでちょっとパンがね俺のいったでいい加減をすごい
5全部しとんじゃなかったものよっ
ていたら 私さん開いている方からからカラーでなぜようん
ん
なんで馬に乗り始めたのなんですか なんか
なんで馬の乗り始めたきっかけって何かあるん もうあの父が馬口がいだったからやっぱり
はぁはっきりだった 父様はの馬が大好きだよ あそうなんだよやっぱり子供の頃から乗っててねーかっ
ん
相当昔ですよね?明治?・・・いや・・・、そんなことないわ! 最初?父は明治よね? いや、やしこさんじゃないのよ。びっくりした・・・。
お父さんがその馬騎士街だった時代っていうのはさ・・・ 明治、明治ってことない?どうぞ。
でも、東大にいた頃、明治が最初になったのかもわからないけど・・・ 昔の方は、結構、軍隊でいっぱい馬持っていた。
今よりは、二次がだったんでしょうね。 学習院なんか、聖火で全員馬に乗らなきゃいけなかった。
でも、なんか、軍馬ですよね。 軍馬です。
やしこさんも入れちゃっていい? はい、お願いいたします。
じゃあ、軽井さんの街中で、馬に乗る時は・・・ スカートじゃ、乗れないですよね。
軽井さんでは、あんまり乗ったことないんです。 東京で毎週乗ってたので。
じゃあ、東京で乗る時は、そういう馬に乗る、ちゃんと格好で乗ればいいですね。
そう、以上で、もう、あしこちゃん、そのキラリー、ありがとうございます。
ありがとうございます
今は街の中で馬に乗ってる人見ることないですからね
ないですね
車でも横通って暴れたら怖い
でも一応道行法上はまだ馬っていいんですよね
自転車と一緒ですので
左側通行で行けばいいんですよ
何もない
実際それをやってる人はいない
危ない
見たことない
あすがに見たことないですよね
いただきます
これ何?ラザーニャ?
もしよかったら
後でもし
ちょっと
氷入れたところから
失っちゃおうか
そこに行く
山本がある
庭に飼っている人もいる
庭に飼っている
いいですね
日本だとちょっと
歴は
歴は終えている?
でも
あれ
すごい大きい農場みたいな
夏の間
今習ったん?
習ったん?
10人
20人くらい
小さい子供がいっぱい
暮らすと
一つの感じで
ユイさんは
飲めるの
今
よくなれ
日のようで
うん
自分の
今
大きい
生まれたばっかり
ちゃんと見なって
うん
こういう
4年くらいで
4歳
うん
4歳で
まだまだね
4歳が
ちょっと
走りたい盛りですよね
うん
もう
つないで
始まる
えっと
そうそう
うん
1年間くらい
まあそうですよね
いきなり行っちゃ危ないから
で、1番
競馬作で最初はね
最初うまく回らないで
こっちに突撃されたりして
危ないですよね
馬がこっちへ来ちゃって
回ってくれないって
冬は簡単に見えるけど
難しいですよね
でも人を乗せないで
馬の運動のためにね
そういうのがありますよね
まあそうですね
馬は知らない人を
こういうことをやると
ことはできない
それから
山岩さん乗りしかいなかった
なかったですね
いろんな
チキスープのおかげる?
あ、はい
こんにちは
教教を
放牧をね
またがしたりとか
ジャンプ
大丈夫
でも、今は
ジャンプが
プロフェッショナルのわけ
一番大事なことが
大人の私は
一番印象に
とったのは
自分で
記事を
準備します
こういう
もっと2回
2回ぐらい
こういうね
自分で
心に帰って
え?
記事を
準備します
うん
で、この
この馬はね
5歳ぐらい
だから
5年前から
よくしているから
この
記事を
準備して
記事は
こういうか
それとも
もっといい
いい
みたいな
で
それ
引きになると
ゴマの上に
え?
えっと
乗せます
乗せる
うん
そういうことができれば
大丈夫
あ、背中をね
背中に
うん
この生地を
乗せる
最初なんか
物見ちゃったり
危ないから
うーん
結構
馬って
敏感なんですよ
うん
でも
とにかく
この
記事の中で自分の手をいろんなメッセージがあって
記念としてね
で、だからうまくいかないと本当に損害する
だいぶ
スイちゃんスープいる?
中までする?
入れとくよ
3点目
それだったらうまく
うーん
で、その役割ね
もし生まれたからね
知っているから
これを100%ね
できるかわからないけども
比率が高いの自分
このまま
この上に乗せる
うーん
デルコートなんですね
そういうのは全然ない
やっとない
うーん
最後に今乗ったのがいつですか?
いつですか?
もう大きな
今乗ってないんですよ
また乗ろうと思ってるんだけど
ちょっとあの
本当ですか?
私の父とか先生方ってもう80代でしたよね
あのゆうささんなんてね
もう90代近くは何になって乗ってらっしゃってたから
本当?
まだ
でもいい馬だったら
うん
こういう
大丈夫です
うん
そう
つまり
えっと
乗る人は
うん
まだ
馬は
家を守る
あそう
まだ乗るんですか?
乗ろうと思ってるの
乗りたい気も
意欲があるということじゃないですか?
できると思う
何でかと言った?
90歳ぐらいでも乗ってる人いますよ
90歳ぐらい
うん
オリンピックだと
ポケツさんという方が75歳で
最高齢で出られましたんで
井上結子さんの事業を通してたよね
うん
馬が運動するんで
人間の筋力が衰えてもそれを補ってくれますので
うん
馬の方のトレーニングさえしとけば
できてれば
できるのは
うん
絶対やります
子は怖くないかな
うんうんうんうん
やすこともね
で、馬は怖いということを
においかな?
すぐに聞いて
そうか
確かにその
その
怖くない
子は
馬はちゃんと伝わるんですね
うん
ヤスコさんの車に付いてて、あれがすごい憧れだったんですって
私の車?
昔はフォードだからスフィックに付いてなかった
車の前に皆さん、馬好きの方付けましたね
実際に使ったやつだね
まだうちいっぱい持ってます
ありがとうございます
全部付けました
馬好きはああいうのを見ると、ここだけピンポイントで
静鉄があるなって
うちも玄関に必ずかけて静鉄を入れてます
演技がいいんでしょ?
そうなんです
って教えていただいたのでね
うちの全部、東京の家の玄関までね
入ったと思われて
いただいて
それも金メッキと銀メッキがあられて
嬉しいよね、ちょっとね
そう
えっと、やつごさんがんばって
気をつけてください
もちろんジャンプがあられてたらいいんだけど
ジャンプがあられてたらいいんだけど
うん
そういうのはどこで乗るんですか?
そのクラブで乗るの?
何?
馬に乗るときってどこで乗るんですか?
今はあの、だからどこかの
ジョークラブに属してないと
でもなんじゃない?
属してるの?
そこがあってそれで
馬に乗る
馬というところがあるんですよ
砂っぽいところが
そこに行ってられたり
今どこ入ってるんですか?
今もう入ってない
入ってないじゃん
千葉に行かれてましたもんね
そう、千葉では馬持ってたんだけどね
民宿のおじさん
うんうんうん
で、彼によると
すごいおばあちゃんは
よくうま
先人よりよく乗ります
うん
だから、これ
いつも
これから寝ればすぐうまくなる
足長いし
あ、そうか
足長いのすごいポイントなんです
やっぱりこう、ハマりがいい
うんうん
そうよね
ちょっとダメだな
笑
日本人は足短いし
から
ドイツの馬とかに乗っちゃうと
うん
上の方にちょっと落ちる感じ
なんか想像できるんだ
ちょっと滑稽な感じ
ドイツ勢がのつぶ足長いから
お腹の下まで
上だけでこうやってる感じで
トゥケさんでも
大丈夫?
何が?
えっと
ドンキー
ロバです
ロバだよ
ロバなんて
ロバ流行ってる
今流行ってる
ロバ
私たちはロバをやりたい
ロバをやりたい
ロバって人を乗せないって言うじゃない
でも
疲れがない
性格がある
ロバ
ロバやだ
ねえちょっと
馬の話してて
ロバになるのが
ちょっと寂しい感じ
せめて
ポニーぐらいに
ポニーさん
大馬か?
ミキは今
ロバすごく気味がある
アメリカ
こうやってるのは? 普通の馬はポニーと行っているんですよ。そのポニーは大きくならないというか…
もともと小さい馬なんですけど、そうなんだ。
最高が140cm以下はポニーということになってますね。
このぐらいかな。それ以上大きくならない。
ならないもの。 そういう馬。
サラブレットだと160cmくらいあるのもいるし、でかいと180cmとか。
西太が金メダルを取った馬は180cm超えてた。
それは背中までですから、背中までが180cmでその上に首がついてるんで、巨大な馬ですよね。
そうですね。乗ったら2m、3mくらい高さですよね。
結構怖いですね。その位置いて。
勝つためにはね、大きいもの。
そういうことなんですね。
深い障害を特に。
これ、おかわりをいかがでした?
今ね。
ありがとうございます。
私はこれを。
岩田さんもちょっと行こうか。
今日は天気持ちそうだ。
持ちそうだけど、昨日は何?
昨日すごかったんですよ。
昨日はね、あの。
食べ始めたら大雨
雷もあった時代でしじきボーンってでも
やんだ
でも昨日本当に食べ始めってその瞬間に始まったからちょっと
あのー、ドキドキしちゃいましたよ
明日台風大丈夫かね
水曜日っていう今のところ予報
お帰りになると台風の
ニュース見てない
台風が来る?
台風が来るけど
もう来てますよ近くに
もう来てるんだよ
前に釣ったら見るよ
あんだけできない間になって
今どこらへんですか?
もうすぐ関東に突撃するらしい
明日ぐらい
そうなんですか?
なんか本当に今回はちょっと上を通りそうな感じですよ
いわしから西に
そうなん
予報を見るとね
倉田さんたちのお点が終わる日の午前中らしいんですね
この辺の雨が
ビルと天がこう
開けていくっていう
なんか今んとこの予報なので
なんとなくそれを見ながら
帰り道は大丈夫かな?っていうね
想像してるんですけど
帰り道は大丈夫だけど
開尾中雨なんですね
あ~そうかそうかそうか
それは皆さんの足が
確かに
これたち明日行けるよね
私たち明日行こうと思って
あっそのとき
確かに
大体やっぱりこう
例年
決まった顔ぶれというか
来られる方
まあそうですね
あの
まあ東京から来る子
結構僕が教えてた学生とか
うんうんうん
まあ乗るついでに来たり
この近く乗るとかあるんで
あ~そうか
あの
生徒市牧場っていうところで
外場して
寄ってくれた子たちがいますね
うーん
山の中歩いて
歩いてって?
馬で?
馬で
へ~
もうできますよ
あそうなんですか?
うんうん
いや
なんかちょっと関心ありますけど
なんかいきなり
何も知らないで乗るには
あの
あまりにも準備ができてない感じ
でもそういうのってやっぱり
童馬クラブに
行くことが
始める
全然乗ったことないって言ったら、ただ歩くだけなら誰でもできますから。
乗ってればいいわけです。
そこは引いてくれないから。
周りにインストラクターがついて、後ろからついていく。
速い足って言って、揺れなきゃ別に落ちませんので、ただ歩くだけ。
その来た子の一人は、僕が教えた子だから、ある程度乗れるんだけど、お友達連れてきたら、彼は全然乗れないので、
だからゆっくり歩いて、1時間で探索を。
すごい楽しかったです。
山の中を歩くときにして、山の中じゃない。
養護クラブのコースじゃなくて。
ある程度山のコースが決まってて、ずっと歩いて行くんですよね。
1時間くらいのコース。
すごく楽しめることがある。
それですか。
白馬の山の上で外場って、馬が何頭も用意されている。
予約すれば。
本当に乗ったことない人も、インストラクターが前に着いて、本当におとなしい馬抱き揃えているから、
半島、4島くらいで、白馬の山の上で。
それ気持ち良さそうです。
いや、全然素人でも大丈夫だ。
そうなんです。
コロンビアはこういうことだ。
昔から。
ありそうですね。コロンビアはね。
ありそうな。
コロンビアはね。
ところが、朝早くに出て山を一周します。
昔ご飯と、あるところで食べて、夜ご飯。
そんなに?
一日ライド。
そうそう、一日。
夜まで。
すごい。
ロバを。
スピカをつけて、
リンコをつけて、
みんな音楽をかけて。
楽しそう。
えっと、
バーみたいな。
飲みながら、
音楽を飲みながら。
ちょっと、2分だけで、
ちょっと酔っ払いながら。
そうそう、酔っ払いだから。
とってもいい。
音楽のスピーカー乗っけたロバがずっとついてきて。
そうそう。
ドロンビアって感じだな
スピーカーとかバールもおせんとか
お酒も
歩くバールみたいな感じ?
それは楽しそう
すごい
そういうロバが何頭かいるってことです
お酒を組んでいるロバと
スピーカーのロバと
お酒を飲みながら
夜も
お酒を飲む
すごい一日楽しそう
すごいよ
夜になる
お酒を飲んで
よっからって落ちちゃう人とか
とてもいい
馬
馬よくてもよっからってたら
でも
よく
この馬はきっと守る
馬が山道を知ってるからね
自分の家までは帰りません
なんかちょっと
スピーカー昇和されたロバも
お前そうな絵
絵面
絵が
背中の両髪を両方にスピーカーも
人間はお酒を飲んで
浮かれて
こんな感じ
ロバのコンペティションが
マラトンみたい
人
ロバを引っ張って
走る
東京マラトンみたい
でもロバ
へー
人が
速く走らないと勝てない
そうそうそう
ロバを引っ張る
ロバが引っ張るんじゃないですよ
人間が引っ張るんですよ
両方ともね
初めに人間だけ
ロバが
協力をしないと
意味がない
それもちょっと
レイクみたいなの?
もしかしたら
言うことを聞かないかもしれないし
うまくこう
ちゃんと意思の
交通ができて
勝ちみたいな
そんな感じなのか
でもとっても
流行っているアメリカ
でもなんか
名古屋な
アメリカで
コロンビアじゃなくて
アメリカ
日本ってあんまり
ロバいないですもんね
あんまり見ないかも
そうだね
普通見るってことですね
ロバがね
そう
コロンビアやたって
普通ある
あ、そう
ロバは
ロバ祭りがあります
えぇ
ロバ祭りがある
ロバ祭り?
えぇ
かわいい
よりかわいい
ロバ祭りすごい
かわいい感じがする
そう
立派なロバがいる
確かに
よく絵になってる
ロバの絵を
うん
ロバって
人間乗せるより
なんかこう
荷物は
そうですよね。
濃厚に使えそうな感じで、馬より手軽ってことですか?
ロバの方から?
そう。手軽。
だんだんロバに乗りたくなってきた。
乗り心地どうなんだろう?
だって小さいでしょね。
実際で必ず手を、子供をかけて。
ロバは、気象は?
おとなしい?
おとなしい。
とっても。
そうなんですね。
なんかちょっと、ロバってどこにいるのか?
頑固ですけども。
生なおに頭が。
ロバは普通におかしいなかったと思う。
日本はあんまりいないですよね。
うまいおにしですよね。
牛は、みのおにしは。
日本はあんまりいかない。
そうですね。
ロバはいなかったと思う。
入ってこなかったんですね。
日本の馬って小さいから小型の馬がいて、それでも使ってたんじゃないですか。
もともと荷物運び用の馬がいっぱいいたんで。
なるほど。
でも、なんか、あのー、なんていうね。頑丈そうなイメージがありますけどね。
そうそうそう。
馬とさんもつないといえば。
はい、こうな。
馬より男性。
頑固。
馬は頑固じゃない。
ロバが。
ロバがとっても頑固。
でも、同じね。
だいたい、もしいい。
いい態度があれば、協力する。
はい。
うーん。
まあまあ大丈夫です。
ロバ。
ロバってやっぱり日本以外、ヨーロッパとか。
あんまり日本じゃないイメージ。
なんか、南米の教科には必ずロバ。
でも、そうですよね。
イエスキリストの入場がロバですもんね。
だから。
宗教的なの?みんなロバ。
馬じゃないですからね。
馬じゃないね。確かにロバになってる。
宗教的な感じは、もしくは馬だけど、宗教的なのはロバって感じ。
確かに。確かになんかそんな感じがしてる。
でもなんか、だんだんロバに魅力を感じるようになりました。
あ、なりました?
うん。
なんでなんか、ちょっとスピーカーを乗せられて、
なんかあの歩くバールのように扱われているロバがなんとなく愛おしく感じてきたんですけど
うん ちょっとの方を聞き上げというかなか人間の生活にすごく近いところにいるような感じが
うるさいでしょうねとかねうん 本格が何がによってもん
どうやってなき声あるんですか?うん アウトリスメンでよなぁ
まあそうかもしれないね まあ音量だから ああそうかー
いやあそうさん 教師の状態にうまんのおくときは
本当
話してると乗りたくなっていくでしょうね きっとね
うん できるとも
うん
「体が覚えてくるでしょうね」
「体が覚えてるでしょうね」
「そうね。もう乗った途端に分かってしまうみたいですよね」
「あの馬の背中に乗っちゃえばもう大丈夫でしょうね。車が高いから」
「乗っちゃえばもう全然、どこでもいける感じでしょうね」
「乗るのは一人で乗れるの?」
「一人で乗れるの?」
「うん。あのー、台があることもあるわよね」
「台を用意しました」
「台ですよね。今は下から乗るのは大変だけども」
「下から乗るのは初めは覚えなきゃいけないですよね」
「あぶみの蔵を持って」
「でも安子さん、私は初めて見たフリシマス」
「うん。本当にそう」
「どんなサイストインプレッションですか?」
「違う人みたい?」
「しっこいコマンドがある」
「とても自信である」
「うん。そう。乗る。そう。乗る。」
「馬に乗る自信?」
「自信。自信しながら馬に乗っていることが」
「乗っていることが」
「そうね。でも初めての馬だったら自信、自信なんてないですよ。全然」
「もう知ってる馬だったらね」
「お互いに知ってれば」
「とても、私よりいい」
「持ってたんでしょ?自分の馬を」
「今乗ってないのよ。だから」
「今も持ってますね。今を」
思ってない。
前は千葉に持ってて、よく行ってましたね。
安子さん、富さん覚えている?
民宿の民宿。
富、富。
このおじさん、富。
私たちは千葉に行った時に、民宿に泊まった。
泊まるところが。
そうすると毎日ご覧になる。
富さん。
富さんとおばあさん、追えているね。
もう泣くなったでしょ、富さんね。
彼が初めてね、
「え、おばあさん大丈夫?野良へ」って言われた。
言われた。
言われると思いますよ、それは。
でも、後でね、見て、
ああ、すごい、お股がする。
驚かれましたね。
そう。
力は追えているね、この、富さんの。
すごい小さい頃。
うん。
力は、安子さんの馬乗ってる姿を覚えてる?
覚えてないか。
覚えてますよ。
覚えてる?
うん。
だって、足音からしてわかるみたいなのよね。
ああ、馬はね、安子さんが近づいていくところに、もう気づくんですね。
ヤスコさんの存在を。
そうだね。
うん。
サラダ、いつかですか?
ちょっと。
よかったらどうぞ。
モロヘイヤのスーツが、
おいでお腹いますか?
うん。
お腹食べてる方。
僕は大丈夫ですか?
大丈夫?
もういっぱい食べました。
うん。
何歳ですか?
25歳。
アメリカに住んでる?
はい。
アメリカに住んでるけど、日本語は低いで、英語も得意。
うん。
いや、英語の方はやっぱり今は…
アメリカ人なんだもんね。
アメリカ人なんだ。
そうそう。
3人とも孫はアメリカ人なんだ。
うん。
でも、あの、敬語とかすごい苦手。
日本語も別に普通にね、しゃべる。
うん。
ヤスコさんも日本語下手なんですよ。
フランスにずっと長くて。
私はフランス語が一番いい。
日本語は話すのはいいんですけど、書けない感じとかいっぱいあるから。
読めない感じもいっぱいある。
ルイスに聞くなよね。
本当に本当に。
私より漢字とか知ってる。
リクさんも知ってるよね。
私よりね。
コロンビア人に漢字を聞く
だってね今だと大体そういう大きいパリとかロンドンとかそういう大きい街だと必ず日本人学校っていうのがあるんですよ
日本人のお子さんたちを1週間に1回でも行かなきゃいけなくて私の孫たちもあれ行けば行かなかったよね
だけど大気とか行って行くようにしてたのよね
だけど私は最初フランスに行った時はもう日本語なんて全然もう聞こえもしなくてフランス語をやるのを知ってもうきちだったんですよね
本当にもうイエスも何も言えなかったから
本当に何にもわからなかったから大変でした
何歳でフランスに行ったの?
小学校終えたところでちょうど12ぐらい
12、3になる時だったかな
いきなりフランスの学校に入るわけですか?
フランス語喋れなくて日本から行って
そうそれでもうクラスに入れられちゃって最初はだから全然できないんですよね
そちらは本当におめでとうございますね
英語だけは日本で私は精神に行ってたんですね
だから英語は小学校だけは少しやってたから
英語の方がフランス語よりはできていて
それでフランスに行った時に英語のクラスとそれから数学、算数のクラスの簡単な計算だけはできたんですけど
それをフランス語で言うことはできなかった
なんか大変だった
それは大変ですよね
本当に大変です
僕ら全然フランス語わかんないでね
フランスで行って
3ヶ月ぐらいフランスでブラブラしてた
この人入院しちゃったんですよ
それでその時すごい困って
アルルで、アルルの総合病院で入院したんだけど
アルルで唯一ある総合病院
そこの一番大きい病院なんだけど
英語が喋れる看護師が一人
ドクターも誰も英語を喋れない
辞書
これこれの名前ね
今はね、あの、翻訳機があるけど
昔は辞書でこうやってやってさしながら
大変です
あなたは今日はここへ泊まるべきだ
ん?
入院?
入院したんだ
入院しちゃって
英語喋れる総合病院
その地区の一番大きい総合病院で
英語が喋れる看護師が一人だけ唯一
ちょっと心細かい
ブーブー言葉もっ 英語ってねフランスで英語ってしゃべらなかった
さからないですよね
私たちが行った時も英語なんかしゃべるん
この人口真似でサバーとかサバーと言った 意味わかってるのとか言った
よくないけどサバって言っておけばいいみたいよ
なんかゲームゲームみたいな
無事にそれをくぐり抜けて今だってよかった
やすこさんの寄宿舎のルーティンもすごく厳しかったですもんねお話伺ったら
朝かしらね私はそうともそれ9 c なんか思わなくてね
全然嫌でもなんでもなかったんだけど
赤ワイン飲んだって言うことによって言ったら
へへへ
いろいろお水があまり良くないから赤ワイン皆さんね
カワインとか飲んでましたね
あのももも当然カトリックの学校だからフランスでしたから
だからあの朝起きた時にあの声をカランカランとかゆかねがお廊下でね
シスターがおならしになるとパッと外へあの寝巻きのまんま出て
お廊下に依存が続くんですよまず
うーん
そうそういうそういう生活をずっとやってて
全然それがもう当然だと思ってたの私は
ただ本当に最近なのよ厳し厳しかったのねとかって言われるのは
本当最近なんですよ私はそれは全然普通だと
普通というか嫌だと思ったことはなかった
その生きのまま外に出るのはちゃんといるかいないかっていうのの確認になるのか?
でももしれなくて同時に朝のお祈りをするから
なるほど廊下に出てみんなでそこでまずお祈りをする
初めの朝起きてお祈りをして
それでまたドア閉めて
マトレスを今度ひっくり返さなきゃいけなくてね
それを目にいらっしゃるのもまたいついつ
マトレスを毎回ひっくり返すんですか?
うん
こういう風に
ええ
今考えれば厳しかったですね学校はね
へぇー
集団生活?
でも歴史さんなんて言いますか?
スペイン語聞いてて覚えたわけでしょ?
学校ではスペイン語ない?
うん
いやスペイン語のクラスはあったけど
やっぱり週一回みたいな
なときのあのトライリングはあるよね
スペイン語も喋れるんだ
いやいやいや
パパがスペイン語だから
スペイン語、日本語すごい
日本語と日本語だけど
いやいやいやいや
特にスペイン語に
聞いて少し分かる
一匹はどの言葉を聞いてても分かるんですか?
好きですか?この抑揚というか?
いや、全部きれいで。
ご家族では英語でしゃべる?
日本語ですよね。
私の娘がね、やっぱりお家では日本語で、そうじゃないと日本語を例えば大学で取りますよね。
それでもこういう普通の日本語って習わないから、しゃべれるようにならないから。
だからお家では日本語をしゃべる。
みんなそう知ってたはずなのね。私の妹が一人いるんだけど、旦那さんがイギリス人なんですね。
それでやっぱり女の子がいて、お家では日本語って言ってたんだけど、エミの日本語変ですよね。
本当に、あの、すごい。
え、言うのも言うの?
うん。もう何年もでも10年くらいあってない。
うん。今だけどもうね。お家にいないから。
あの、ボストンでやってた。
うん、ボストン。
そう。今ね、バイティが、えっと、きって、びっくりしたことが、うん。
しましたから、私はあなたはどういう音楽、うん。
好きな音楽を教えてください。
エスペイン語だった。
エスペイン語の音楽。
エスペイン語で。
タイキ?
タイキが日本語一番上手よね。書けるんで、それこそ私より書けるのよ。
書けるの。
カイキに弾けるの。
本当。
でも、わからないですよね。
全然わかんないですよね。これだけしゃべれてると、その紙書いっていうのよくわかんないですよね。
うん。
だって日本語ってやっぱり、読みかけが大変だから。
アンビカとドアアルです。
アメリカでスペイン語が載せる。
ドッキュセイガ。
うーん。
あの、大輝のね。
うん。
ピックにしました。
アンビちゃんと喧嘩するときは英語なんですよ。
ああ、うん。
アンビちゃんと喧嘩するの。
そうそう。
そうなんだ。
考えてみればそうだね。
感情が高ぶったときに出るのは英語なんですかね。
うーん。
なんでかな。
でも、私はね。
それぐらいできるようになると言うけど、
アメリカのネットシンに行きました。
いや、うん。
で、こういう印象がアメリカヒートが、
例えば私は、ラティノ、スペイン語が話せる人が、
集まって、何よりも楽しみ。
わいわいわいわなんとか楽しみ。
アメリカヒートが、
長にメンメンの英語を聞いて、英語で話すように言えば英語ができるように。
国とね、そうがあったのよ。国と私と英語で話そうって決めてね、スウェーデンに行った時に。
それで、いつも英語で話してる。
そうだ、この前どこで習ったって言ったでしょ、英語。
私の英語で話すようになった。
話せるようになったのは国の関連なんです。
英語で話すようになった。
英語なのに、英語とかしてる。
べきではないけれども、どういう。
でも、すごいうまいじゃん。全然普通の英語っていう感じ。
ルイシさん一番好きなのはやっぱりスペイン語でしょ。
スペイン語でその次は英語。
英語。
リキー、あなたはアメリカ人の一般的に、集まって、ラティノの集まったら、冗談とか楽しい話があるじゃない。
わいわい。
でも、アメリカ人は、討論するじゃない。
中国では。
あ、そういう事でしょ。
ちょっと少し証拠を覧めてる。
私は中国の…
そうね、ヤスコさん、中国の…
そっか、わかんない。
ヤスコさん、同じだと思って。
いらっしゃらなくなっちゃったから、やめちゃったのよ。
そうなんですよ。
アメリカは好きってこと。
アメリカは。
リベート?
リベートみたいな。
日本はあんまりやらないから。
でも、そもそもこのリベートだ。
私、アメリカ人ではないから、でも見ると、大喧嘩ですけどもね。
実際にこのディスカッション、リベートだ。
年齢とグループによって違うかな。
アメリカ人も持ってきますね。
最近もね、それ頼んだら、最近断られた。
え?なんで?
なんかね、人によって、この人は英語の人とか、この人とはフランス語とかって。
人はね、人と語学は一緒になってて、めめはいつも日本語だったから、今も英語なんてダメだって。
だけど、急に私はなんか英語で言うと、気が付くんないのよ。
え?そう?
全然英語でパッて答えてくる。
ああ、そうだよね。今。
行きましょう。
テキストも全部英語だもんね
英語とフランス語もちょっと違うから
色とかも白がホワイトじゃないし
ブランス
イメージがもう頭の中ぐちゃぐちゃになりますよね
そうね
何だろう
何でダウンとは考えないんですよ
考えて訳してると大変だから
白をしろってまず思って
それからホワイトって言ったらダメだけど
それからポッとホワイトって思えるようになれば
もうそれで
フランス語でもそうよね
フランス語でもやってらっしゃるんでしょ
やってないです全然
何十年前だっけ
何も知らないで行って
三十年前の話だって
私も電車の中で教えてくれたりするんだよね
発音が違う
アルルでおられる
アルルって言ったらノーノーノー
アルルかって言って
アルルが言えるまで何回も罰が
日本にない発音なんで
アルルルって言えるまで
だいぶ教えてもらいました
周りの人たち
日本人は割とみんなどうせ日本語なんか知らないだろうからって
心切にゆっくりねしゃべったりする時
向こうの人ってバーっとこうしゃべってきて
そうね分かる方が当然そうですよね
面白かったです
道聞かれた時びっくりしましたね
全然知らない僕に聞かないでほしい
フランス語で
初めてのとこへ来て道を聞かれても
もっと聞く人は隣にいるように
そういうアンマークベットの
いろんな人がいるから分かんないみたい
そういう感覚があんまりないみたい
日本だとね日本人がほぼ日本人って分かるから
外国のちょっと違うから言われたら
外国人だなと思って丁寧にできるけど
フランスにしても人種の留守というか
黒人もいるし
黄色人もいっぱいいるから
誰でもこの人でもフランス人にいたのかもしれないなって
いろんな人がいる中でなんで僕が聞くんだよ
初めて来たところです。
画材を背負って、こっちも荷物を背負って、
今日のお宿はありますか?ということで、お湯は出ますか?
そういうの難しいですよね。
1週間ずつ、初めパリに行って、それからクエルモンペランとか、山の方に入って、
南北まで何かに行って、
ニースとかね、普通のいいところでしたね。
エイスとか、
アルピスの方行って、シャモンに行って、
1週間くらい行って、
大体、移動して1週間くらい、
何時間かは必ず行って、
6、9日。
絵を描きながら。
絵を描きながら、すごい。
すごい楽しかった。
コースタン、しっかりやっていただいて、
もうちょっと、
回しましょうか。
1週間くらい、
本当だ?それ何? タイキヤ知ってそうな…クワガタ虫… クワガタだ。クワガタ取る? メスです。 フルーツの匂い。
フランスに転々として、そこで泊まって、何日間からそこで生活するから、市場に行ってみたり、その地域のなんか…山の方はお肉のウサギとかね、そういうもので市場に行くと、こうやってウサギの耳もって品定めしてるんでしょ?
ウサギ食べるんですよね。 ペットじゃなくって、あれは食べるんだっていう。
ちょっとワイルドな感じでしたね。ウサギの耳もこう…買うか買うのか…
食べ物もちょっと…フランスの味に疲れちゃって…食べ物ないかなって…
ベーコンっていうのがあって、あっ、ベーコンなら食べれると。日本の感覚って薄く切ったベーコンを…って感じだったら、なんか酢漬けのキャベツのこれぐらいのベーコンがどんどん来て…
フランスの…フランスの…フランスの…何もかも…なんか、こっちのイメージ…
を超えていくから
食べ物は全然大丈夫でしたか?
そうね、あの 最初に学校の寄宿舎に入れられたときはちょっとやっぱり
何が困ったっていうのはないんですけど、ちょっと慣れるのに時間がかかりましたね
お昼と晩と両方急に学校になっちゃって、だからちょっと大変だったけど
もちろん3食フラン
朝はパンとバターだけなの、それとカフェオレがこんな大きいので
入院したときに3時のおやつ、飲み物が出るけど
何を飲むかって聞かれて、何があるの?って言ったら
紅茶とミルクと
入院なさったの?
はい
大変でしたね
夜寝る前も、9時に何か寝る前に飲むかってきて、何があるの?って
ハーブティーと、なんとかちょっと、あ、ちゃん、ハーブティー、ハーブティーって
一応体験しておこうと思って
病院食も肉にするか、魚にするかって聞かれました
うん
すごい
っていう
いきなり食べちゃうんですね、肉も魚も
うん、なんか聞かれたから、じゃあ肉?とか
あははは
うん
3時のおやつ、全部、全部飲み物も聞かれて
自分で日本人だと、いや何でもいいですとか、なんかそれだとダメなんですよね
うん
私はココアが欲しいとか、うん
なんかちゃんと自分で主張しないと
うん
それが外国のね、文化としては
あ
よかったら取って、回して
これいただきます
どう?
そして
うん
チェイちゃん
一つ、一ついただきます
ありがとう
イシカはどうですか?
ん?
いやいやもう大丈夫だ
はい、じゃあこれ一ついただきます
はい、こちらへ
はい、ありがとうございます
あの、ジンジャエルどっちがいいですか?
あ、ありがとうございます
おいしい、ジンジャエル
これ、作るのないの?
あ、これ作るの?
これ、作るの?これ、口付けてないから
あ、いやいやいや
さっきのお茶、そこでいただいたのもおいしかった
本当にお聞き?
ふだたさんもジンジャエル入れますか?
あ、そうですか、じゃあジンジャエル
おいしいジンジャエル
うん
いいなぁ
ヤスコさんのウクレレ
映画って言われるんです
ウクレレやってましたよね
あーもうやってないの
もうやってないんですか
そうか
なんかどうしたか
じゃあ中国語の先生とそれからウクレレの先生と
お二人同士にお辞めになっちゃったんですけど
一人もお亡くなりになっちゃったの
うんうんうん
それでなんかだから両方やってて
ちょうどいいものをね
選んだって妹なんか言ってたんだけど
急に両方やらなくなっちゃった
あ、それは残念
でも中国語は
時々
辞書見て文章作ってました
中国人のね
お友達の神父様がいるの
あ、そうなんですか
はい
とってもいい
あ、やっぱいられるぞ
すごくかわいしい
昔
あ、フランシス
フランシス
チャペルの主任主題が
中国人
前
今は
えっと
中道院で
セタ
だから全然
あえんな
今は、中道院で教えていたんだ。
だから、全然あいつもあいつも。
ヤスコさん、ウクレレ習ってたの知ってる?
知る。
今、先生がちょうどいらっしゃらなくなった。
それは、こうなんて、だからまた先生。
他のこと、スペイン語とかだとね、少しやって、なんかちょっと言えるじゃない。
どこそこ行きました、ぐらいだけ。
中高だと言えないのよ、そのくらいの簡単な言葉。
習ってたんですか?生学校?
生学校?生学校で習ってた?
クラスに入ってたのよ、ちゃんと。
何年ぐらい?
何ぐらいだったの?
8年ぐらいかな。初め10年ぐらいだったんだけど、すぐ8年ぐらいになって。
何年間で、どこそ行くか。
うちのもやるなかったんだ。
だから、そうがないよね。
そうがないよね。
そうがない。
うん。
そうやった。
体がちょっと温まっ
秋っぽくなったよね、この水が
これ、今ね
私にこういう温度が寒い
寒い
あったかいところ
寒い?
もうダメです
持ってきました
暑い方が得意なんでね
そうか
エビキは?
全然反対
パパだっけ?
厚刈りです
こないだおかしかったんだよ
大輝がね
うちにご飯食べてるときにね
パパがね
お友達と約束があって
出かけるときにね
パパがね
送ってきてあげるっていうからね
だから
ああでも
違う場所だからいいって言ったけど
パパがとてもね
熱心に送ってってあげるっていうから
乗ったらね
すごい遠回りになっちゃってね
すごい時間かかっちゃったって怒ってたよね
うん
これぐらいはあるけど
あははは
うーん
ねえ
なんか
あったでしょ
どっちでしょ
あった?
車の音でしょ
なんか開け閉めした音だってこと
そうそう
クラットさんに
馬に触れられる機会が
今年の1月あったのね
そうなんですね
そうですね
年に1回
いろんな人を呼んで
初乗り会っていうのをやるんです
お呼びしようかなって
ちょっと
うん
ねえ
お母さんちょっと
寒いからね
1月は
ねえ
1月誘われるけど
行きたくないの
寒いかい
寒いですよ
ああ
下が凍ってるんだもん
馬場が
うん
下柱
あっ
そうかそうか
1月だから
1月だからね
うーん
でもみんな初乗りだから
その年初めての乗馬する日だから
夏森で集まるから
うん
皆さんも誰
だいたい僕が主催なので
皆さんに声かけて
ちょっと人数少ないとあんまりね
せっかくやったのに
家族も呼び出されたりして
私はどこでやるんですか?
東福祉でやってる
市も
早稲田の馬場だ
ああそうなんです
はい
小平のあたりですか?
小平のあたり
ちょっと手前ですね
手前ぐらいですね
新宿から20分くらい
近いね
ありがとう
すごい
これね
えっと
ベーシルとミント
へぇー
これ何?
ルイさん家に食べてたの?
そう食べてた
だからドライヤンしたら
セッキとか
本当に
お花ももらっていいの?
ありがとう
いい香り
ねえ
やすこさん
欲しくない?
少し分けましょうか
私もそのままもないんだ
お客様
今
ミキのせいで今
え?
車が
ミキちゃんのせいで
どうかは分からないけど
でも
正しき選択が
あ~
ちょうどいいじゃないですか
いつ頃フランスにいらっしゃいました?
何年頃?
いぶ前ですよ
25年前?
30年ぐらい
私ももっと思い
私は1905…
なんと…
それこそすごい年代が分かった
1955年からね
61年まで
だからすごくうまいんだよ
本当に
61まで
いや~私まだ生まれてないです
そう?
そうですね
僕生まれたのが61年です
うん?
生まれたのが61年
1955年
それで最初の時にトンコさんにも最初にお会いしたの
あ~そうなん
うん
パリでしたもんね
そうなのよね
うんうん
結婚してましたよね
だから
なんと私も結婚して
それであのミキが生まれたぐらいになった時に
初めてトンコさんになった
あ~大きくなったわねって私はおっしゃったんだよ
ちょっと困ってないですけど
これはパパと
うん
これはいい
これカネです
そう
どうぞ
どうして?
大丈夫よ
ルイスさんここ
さあ一ついったら
もう一ついったら
これやばい
うーん
全部全部
もう一つ
最近カヌレづいてるから
ルイさんよく当てました
あ~これ
おいしい
これ
最近ヒットしてるのよね
これもさ
そう
一緒
一緒一緒一緒
うん
一緒
これさ、耐熱なのかな?これにさ、今のハーブティー入れてるってどうだろうね
ちょっと、せっかくなので、あのー、ルシちゃん、あのハーブティー入れていきますね。入れてみるね
もうちょっと障害いく?
あ、じゃあお願いします。
あ、私もお店の間が入ってる。
入ってる?
これはヤスコさんの?
これ、こっちか。
無捨てちゃえば?
いい?入れちゃって。
無捨てちゃって大丈夫よ。
いいわよ。
あの、お花に。
そのくらいだった。
ちょっと捨てちゃいます。
はい、いいけど。
あ、この捨てちゃった。
よっか。
この頃はでも、もうお母さん。
ヤナは生まれてないから、結婚はしていいかね。
あの、フランスでおやすこさん。
ありがとうございます。そのくらいでいいわ。
はい。
ごめんね。
ごめん、ごめん。
はい。
ごめんね。
なんかこういう風にする子が本当に上手 criminal 000のこと!
あとどこにするだろう、
Neder 2年間。
でも奥さんはアメリカで?
今、私の仕事がアメリカです。
でもクライアントがここへ。
日本の方が長い?
今年、でも5月26日。
それで戻って。
日本は暑いから。
アメリカも暑いんですか?
今年、暑かったね。
ワシントンの方が。
5月、8月、8月1日から。
暑かった。
ニューヨークはすごい暑かった。
フランスも暑くてね。
40度とか。
そうしよう、その時がニューヨークになった。
一番暑かった。
学校が出ていない
実は今次日本はいくつ
多分冬
お正月
クリスマスからお正月が一番
空いてるので
田舎が見られる
ゆっくりと
安子とアメリカを打ちにくるんですか
考えてない
1年に1回はね
ミキと会いましょうっていうことを
言ってたのだけど
今度彼女が来てくれちゃったから
だから今すぐ行かないで
来年にしようかどうしようか
もしかしたら
クリスマスの前に
ちょっと来てもいいしって言ってるんだけど
ルイスはいつ行くんだっけ
26日
今月
そうかじゃあちょっと早すぎるかな
私にはね
どうしようか
次にアミちゃんがもしかしたら来る
だからそしたらアミと一緒にね
帰ってきたらいいんじゃないって言うんだけど
分かんない
アミちゃんいつ頃来るだろう
分かんないね
ちょうどアミも冬だと思う
いや
去年も冬
来たっけ
それと2年前
2年前
冬
うん
ん?
去年夏だった?
来たん?
うん?
えっとアメリカ
ワシントンに来たん?
去年5月ぐらいだったと思う
うん
去年行ったのはいつ頃だかもう忘れちゃった
あの秋だったと思う
うん
やっぱり
お父さん寒いっすか?
大丈夫?
ん?
寒くない?
夏もん
大丈夫です
でもアミちゃんも日本に来たいでしょ?
夏も
うん
ウィキがそう言ってるけどでも分かんないけど
夏色々あって
冬休みが一番
絶対空いてるって分かる感じかな
ルイスさん気をつけてくださいね
気分って
うん
で
今
大丈夫?
私
多分
切った時に
いよたいが
たくさんあった
うん
もう変えるかな
変えるは
多分
大丈夫
えっと
今日は月曜
土曜日で8時
今日は空いてる
今日は
今日は大丈夫だと
一番危ないのは
受体じゃない
受体で
高速で止まってる
夜は見えないから
2時間目
3時間目
2時間半から3時間
早くて2時間
早くて2時間半
普通に行くと3時間ぐらい
休憩しないで2時間半
休憩しないで渋滞全然なくて
うちまでだとちょうど2時間半くらい
まあだいたいちょっと休んだりして
3時間以上
違って
夏の最後のコースが コロナになってからいろいろオンラインになって意外とこうやって
なんか日本に行ったりとか コロナになってからいろいろオンラインになって
それっきりいろいろ便利になったから
オンラインの方が楽でしょ?
日本に行かなくてもいいし 日本に行っても授業が受けられる
日本で授業を受けられない
あと夜の間だから
2歳があるから
そうから夜って
夜の勉強しながら
朝の1時から
1時?
3時かな
1時から
今日も
13時間
こっち13時間
違いで
これもまだちょっと大変だね
夜中に便利しなきゃいけない
ちょっとくらいね
9時くらいからさ
1時から勉強
頭が
でも逆になっちゃうね
暮らしがもう
夜は逆転しちゃうね
昼夜が
でも毎日じゃないの?
うんうん
いや毎日じゃない
でしょ
録画とかで決める?
そういうわけですか?
いやできる
なんか他の生徒ズルしてる子がいて
なんか
問題になったよね大学で
うちの大学で
単位を早く欲しいから
2つのビデオを流して聞いてますってふりをしたらバレちゃって
大問題だ
5倍速ぐらいでこっちをかけて
早く書いていただいて
内容はともかく早く終わらせれば1つを聞いたってことになるから
画面を2つ分割にして5倍速ぐらいで聞きました
2単位取っちゃうみたいな
それはバレちゃうらしくて
呼び出しとかくらってます
コンピューターとか機械のこと学生の方が詳しいから
いろんなことを考えて先生の上を行く
2分割にして5倍速で聞くのも家にいるかどうか分かんないですもんね
まあそうですよね
どっか遊びに行っててね
どこでだってできますよね
ここでずっと回しながら自分は花火でもしてたって言うんだよね
絶対同じ
リギューターちゃんとやってんの
いやーなんかテストがもう60…全部テストなので宿題が多分30から40%ぐらいの成績になって後は全部テスト
前からずっとそうだったからあまりそういう意味では変わってない感じ
テストはライブなんでしょ?
そうそうそう
うん
その場でやるわけですか?
そう
でもそれ終わってるので
それも日本でできる?
いやいやいやそれえっと…
えっと…なんていうかテストの学教室みたいな…
教室行かなきゃいけない?
そう
それまで帰ってないって何もない?
あ、いえっともう終わって…
あの…
最後に3つぐらいの…なんか…論文じゃないけど小さい…
レポート?
レポートみたいなのがあってそれ終わらせなきゃいけない…
うーん…
こがね虫かね
そうそう
こがね虫っぽい
こがね虫?
うん…こがね虫…
あと亀虫が…
あー…カモ虫の子もありますね…
でも私はツヌミ…この匂いがあったってそんなに…
えぇー…
俺も全然言っちゃわない…
そう…
私結局…
えぇー…
カメ虫…
なんでみんなそんなワワ言うんだろうと思う…
えぇー…
ほんと…
私も…
結構…
インパクトが…
全然にわかんない…
全然私も…
えぇー…
何もでも干しててカメムシが付いた時にはもう…
大変大変
あれは違うでしょ?
あれはこうガネムシ
ガネムシ
これは…
これが一番重要だから
なんかあの酒井神父様がね
あのパクチーとカメムシの匂いが似てるっていうのを
うーん
私それがよくわかんないけど
でもちょっとこの間なんか
あれもうしかしたらこんな感じなのかしらって
なんか…
同じ系統の…
同じ系統のなんかがあるのかしら
うん
おねつ系統の匂いと思う?
うーん
なんか…
どうといい匂い?
え?
あー…
そっか…
しかない?
スカンクはあんまりいないな
どうもプレイに行かないと…
スカンクに会ったことはない?
スカンクの匂いがそう…
それが…
そうなんだ
スカンクに言うよ
会ったことあるんですか?
私…会ったことだけでなく…
私たちはね…
犬…犬を飼ってた
でもこの犬が…
アメリカに行ったもんじゃないかと…
パパがもついたはずって…
はぁ…
パパと…
からね…
スカンク…
パンちゃん…
パンちゃん?
スカンクに襲われて…
そう…
それを…なのに…
スカンクに襲われて…
スカンクの匂いがアパートに入れて
でもさ、なんでスカンクの匂いだってわかったの?
見てたの?襲われるところ
アメリカに出てスカンクがいっぱいいる
いっぱいいね、このボストンのアパートの外に
公園から出られるじゃない?
ところが、すっごい綺麗なこの
私としてすっごい綺麗なの?
すごい綺麗なの?
すごい臭いんだ
私のボタンク
私としては1階1階
4階1階もアパートがあった
3枚で、この2人ともホテルに出てきました
そんなに匂い取れないのね
犬自身は匂いはどうなんですか?
鼻が敏感だから
スカンクがこの匂いをエスプレイしました
犬が逃げて、アパートに入って
全部のアパートの建物が
犬が浴びたそのまま
犬が、アパートに入って、かわいそうだったね
自然自分の体からスカンクの匂いが
ね、だって
向こうは寄せ付けないための匂いだから
よかった、日本はスカンクいないでよかったよね
いないのかな?
いないね
聞いたことない、見たことない
でもこういう、再建する
そうそう、ガラエキ
アライグマ
アライグマはいるー
家だって、大変だったんだって
大変だったんだって
小田道のお家
うちの庭にも、埼玉の
アライグマ
アライグマって、なんか
アライグマ可愛い
可愛いですね
可愛い
可愛いんだけど
猫とか襲っちゃうし
凶暴なんだよね
アライグマ、ラスカルのイメージで
それ、なんで見たんですか
うちの庭にいたんですけど
アライグマって、どれくらいだな
猫一回り
尻尾がこんな
可愛いですよ
一応、なんか雰囲気が可愛いですね
だけど、結構怖いですね
野生のやつなんですよね
空き家にね、住みついて
へー
うちの隣の家はね、屋根の裏に
巣作っちゃって、子供産んじゃくて
子供産じゃ
荒井島の中に、なんかあの、薄皮芯とかが屋根の死につくと、すごい大変だって、この間テレビでやってた。
匂いだね。
屋根の色。
でも、薄皮芯は駆除できないんですかね。
荒井島は害虫なんで、駆除。
ああ、そうなんだろうね。薄皮芯はなんか悪いそう。
どうしたんですか?今、もう駆除されたんですか?
いや、死によって、業者が来てくれて、庭に網を設置してくれたんです。
捕獲する網を、業者がこう、リンゴの中にコロンと入れて、1週間置いといて、引っかかったら連絡くださいって。
もうね、網を置いたらもう来ないんですけど、分かって。
結構賢いの。
でも、来なくなったんだろうね。
まあ、それで、実際来なくなったね。
よかったですよね、それは。
何回も来てたのに。
うちに、木鉢って庭でね、実家から持って、これぐらいの木鉢が来て、そこにメダカを買ってたんですよ。
かわいい。
水分増えて、もう20匹ぐらいいたんですよ。自分で売った時と。
水中の花とか置いて。
へぇー。
それがね、ある時からメダカがいなくなって、あれー?おかしいなーって。
最後1匹になって、これはおかしいって、死体もないんですよ。
えぇー。
で、唯一の1匹を大事にしてたな。
その最後の1匹も亡くなって、荒い熊が来て、
とはって、うんうんうん。
え、お家の中に庭ですね。庭か。
あ~。
え~。
でも、あんなちっちゃい、こんなのをね、すごく器用、いや、コインとかこんな大きいんだったら、見つかめると思う。
こんなちっちゃいメダカ、全部なくなるぐらい。だから結構器用で。
へぇー。
賢い。
で、メダカ全部食べ尽くした、もう来ない。
へぇー。
そうなんだ。
そういうと、メダカでもいらっしゃったり、リ、リキの、あれ、ほら、なんだっけ、あんこうじゃなくて、なんだっけ、
ポル、ポルファベリティ。
あれあれ、ほら、ナマズ。
あぁ、あ~。
ナマズが最後、その水槽から出ちゃった。
あぁ、かわいそうだったね。
ナマズ、勝ってた。
勝ってた。
ナマズって、カイツだったのよね。
うん、いや、最初ナマズだってわかってなかった。
そうなんだろう。
あ、そうなんだろう。
何だと思ったの?
なんか、サメ、サメみたいな、小さいサメでかっこいいなと思った。
小さいかな。
みんな形してたよ。
小さいサメだと思ったら、ナマズって大きくなるでしょ。
うん、そうなんだ。
大きくなってますよね。だから、このくらいの水槽に勝ってと、それで入らなくなるって、楽しみにしてたんだよね。
そうだっけ。
大きくなるの?
どうしちゃったの?
最後が雷があって、
暴れて。
私たちは、
切った時に生きているので。
その後まだ何ヶ月か生きたんだよね。
雷が怖かった。びっくりしちゃったの?
何かで暴れて。
暴れて。
やっぱり音が敏感なのね。
その大きさはどのくらいになったの?
そんなに?
でも、後ろに、
だんだんね、
コミックになってくれ。
もう、こういう。
夢はこんな、家にあって、そこに生地がいる。
大変だ。
もう、かわいい。朝の。
うん。
朝と。
お前作ってたの?
名前何だったっけ?
ポルポエッティだったって、いつも。
それ、金魚。
金魚の名前。
ポルポエッティ。
お前、かわいいね。ポルポエッティって、金魚の名前。
そういうのも変わらないよ。
いろんな動物がいたから、あのー…モルモットもいたね。ハムスターとかいたね。
ハムスター、うちも買いました。
ハムスターが自由に家へ。全部の人が来たら、こういうことに行ったら、もう死にそうで。
どういうこと?どういうこと?
彼らが、ハンスターが刑事にお使わない。自由で家へ。
初めてから?
一応、会ったけど、話してた。
本当に、匂いのハムスター。
怖い。
やっぱり、怖い。
足元ハムスターが走って、ネズミハムスター。
そうそう。
本当に、ちょっとびっくりするかも。
名前付けしてたよね。一匹。一匹。
そういうことが。
だから、人が来た時に、みんなが合わせて、確信する。
ん
くそ大丈夫かいいがます もうすいません帰りますかはいやりたくないといけないん
ブーブー言っていた方がいいかもん いやっこさんもっふーれさっきましたん
ん
うんありがとうさあお名前言ってたことしようやっぱりねん
we have we have lunch together and then i want to take it to some place
あまりも日にちがないんでも今年だけはの tt でもいいなんじゃなくても
本当に来られていかっきゃですまたもう2年2年以上カレーザー来てなくて
ああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ 次も次もも行っているあの気が入りってね
間でいくねとねっ ドリキャーここにないんだもんだからうん
うん 今度また同じ場所たぶん
おっ 受け付けたらいい
ん 私はの実物があるんだけどそうですよねでもこれを
ん 今度は一つの間にあるんですけどねーっ
ん スゴイん
ん スゴイん スゴイん
ん スゴイん スゴイん スゴイん
ん スゴイん スゴイん スゴイん スゴイん
今年が馬の年です これさ、物置に付いてないから最後、よかった これ全部に付きました
守り神的な感じのありがたい 玄関にあると魔除けになるっていう
ヨーロッパーがあるとね、皆さんこういうのを付けて
うちとちもその話を聞いて、すべての建物にありがたくいただいて、この機能です
ありがとうございます
特別な…
これ持ってく?
馬やられてる人はね、自分の馬の手で付くとね
ありがとうございます。
本当にありがとうございます。
ラッキーが回ってきます。
2億のパートの限界に。
いいですね。
ラッキーは、ラッキーを使っています。
大丈夫です。
ラッキーは、ラッキーの車のままに。
ラッキーを使っています。